The SCP Foundation specializes in tracking
anomalous creatures, entities or objects,
and protecting mankind by keeping these anomalies
contained.
It doesn’t happen very often though, that
an SCP surrenders itself to the Foundation,
offering to be contained without putting up
a fight.
You might think that would be a welcome change
for the Foundation’s personnel, getting
an easy containment like that rather than
having to devote valuable time, resources,
and even lives to capturing an anomaly.
But then you have to ask the obvious and worrying
questions.
How did this anomaly know where to find the
Foundation so that it could turn itself in
in the first place?
Did somebody send it, and if so, why?
Well don’t worry, you don’t need to try
and imagine this scenario, because an SCP
turning itself over to the Foundation under
mysterious circumstances has actually already
happened.
One day, security personnel at an SCP Foundation
containment site opened the front door to
find an SCP just sitting there on the doorstep.
The anomaly was brought in for questioning,
and while it was soon designated SCP-032,
it has sometimes been known by another name:
Brother’s Bride.
SCP-032 is a person, or rather a replica of
a person.
Not a living statue that moves whenever you
look away, or a waxwork that comes to life
when the sun goes down.
No, this replica is far stranger.
SCP-032 resembles a human woman around thirty
years of age.
Who made her, who she is supposed to resemble,
and just where exactly she came from are all
still questions the Foundation have been unable
to answer.
But what their research teams have been able
to determine is what she is made from.
Brother’s Bride consists largely of plastics,
at least the external portion of her body.
Her “skin” is made from a combination
of 5.5 millimeter thick silicone and other
plastic fiber polymers, all colored with a
pigment to more closely mimic the shade of
Caucasian human skin.
SCP-032 has been referred to as a “Type-F
human simulacrum” by the Foundation, meaning
that she has an imperfect outward resemblance
to a human being, and the internal workings
of her body are drastically different from
an ordinary human’s organs or central nervous
system.
What does SCP-032 have instead?
Well, she lacks a skeleton or any of the other
internal parts that make up a human body.
Instead, her insides are entirely refined
liquid oil.
However, in spite of having no bones, no organs,
and existing as just pure oil filling up a
plastic skin, SCP-032 has no problem moving
on her own, or communicating verbally.
When she was first discovered waiting outside
the Foundation’s Slovakian compound, Brother’s
Bride claimed she had come there “to be
stored.”
SCP-032 is imperfect in how closely she resembles
a human being, and this becomes more apparent
the closer one gets to her.
At a distance, she can maintain some illusion
of appearing to be fully human.
However, her appearance becomes less and less
convincing as someone approaches.
Naturally, the sight of an uncanny, rubbery
almost-human is enough to unsettle someone,
perhaps even cause discomfort.
But this also happens to be unrelated to SCP-032’s
anomalous abilities, which she detailed to
Foundation personnel when she was first contained.
The Foundation security team that discovered
SCP-032, patiently sitting and waiting to
be found, questioned her motives and how she
had come to be there.
There was no record of what time she might
have arrived on the compound’s security
cameras, and SCP-032 gave the personnel no
inkling as to how she knew the location of
the Foundation’s Slovakian site.
Somehow, she’d managed to approach without
being spotted by anyone, but would not explain
how she had done so.
Security personnel at the site were obviously
skeptical, and asked Brother’s Bride why
she had come to the Foundation.
SCP-032 claimed that her creators had commanded
her to, that she was to be placed in “indefinite
storage, until claimed”.
Although the silicone-based woman appears
to possess a normal level of cognitive function,
she claims she is not fully sapient, meaning
SCP-032 does not possess the intelligence
or understanding of other human beings, at
least according to her.
By her own admission, SCP-032 is an intermediary,
acting on behalf of her creators, although
the SCP Foundation has yet to be able to verify
this.
As for her anomalous abilities, SCP-032 was
kind enough to detail these to the security
personnel that first found her.
She has an innate ability to influence any
biological entity in her immediate vicinity.
In other words, any organism that gets too
close.
Well, not quite any, there is a limitation
to her power.
SCP-032 can only affect a creature or organism
not created by, related to, or influenced
by humanity.
So, plants, animals, even microorganisms like
bacteria, all fall into the category of things
that SCP-032 has an effect on.
According to the various tests the Foundation’s
researchers have conducted, the exact nature
of how SCP-032’s abilities work seems to
vary.
But her presence always causes massive and
irreversible damage to an animal or organism’s
ability to exchange or use energy.
For example, when SCP-032 is surrounded by
wild flora, these plants will lose the ability
to conduct the process of photosynthesis.
They therefore can no longer produce or consume
energy, preventing them from continued growth
and ultimately causing death.
In much the same vein, any animals that come
into close contact with SCP-032 will find
themselves unable to use their respiratory
or digestive systems, rendering them unable
to breathe oxygen, or properly consume food.
Not even germs and other microorganisms are
safe from SCP-032’s effects, although when
it comes to these microscopic life forms,
her ability seems to focus solely on their
reproductive systems, and if bacteria cannot
divide itself, it cannot spread.
At present, the SCP Foundation keeps Brother’s
Bride housed in an automated containment unit,
restricting the amount of direct contact personnel
can have with her.
Unless they are there to conduct authorized
experiments, or other necessary research related
tasks, staff are to leave SCP-032 alone.
Any interviews with her are not even carried
out in person, and instead researchers use
a remote communication array to ask SCP-032
more about her origin, her creators, and her
abilities.
This probably seems a little over-cautious,
right?
After all, SCP-032 has no effect on the human
body, and isn’t aggressive or outwardly
hostile.
Maybe locking her in a room is excessive.
But remember, her degenerative abilities do
affect microorganisms and bacteria, even those
that are beneficial to human beings.
The human body is full of good bacteria that
aids with digestion and helps the body absorb
nutrients - like the ones you’ve heard about
in ads for probiotic yogurt.
Since 032’s effects don’t discriminate
between “good” and “bad” bacteria,
people have to keep their distance from SCP-032
or else they might find that they can no longer
digest food properly.
In fact, no biological material is allowed
anywhere near her, no house plants, no pets,
nothing.
Oddly, SCP-032 herself seems fine with this,
and has never expressed any desire for any
form of comfort, and does not appear to require
sustenance like food or water.
Shortly after she was first contained by the
SCP Foundation, SCP-032 was interviewed by
Doctor Alexander Kovac, the resident psychologist
at the site where Brother’s Bride was discovered.
Doctor Kovac initially tried to ask SCP-032
to disclose her name, however she was unable
to do so.
“I don't have one.
People have names.
I'm not one.”
She then went on to explain that even her
creators had no name for her, and that she
was instructed to cooperate with the SCP Foundation.
Doctor Kovac pressed on, asking about when
she’d told security that she was to be stored
until collected, who SCP-032 had meant was
coming to collect her.
Her answer was as enigmatic as could be expected,
she claimed that she was going to be collected
by someone her creators wished to torment,
and finding her in the hands of the SCP Foundation
would bring this person greater suffering.
Kovac asked if this person was a part of the
Foundation, assuming that SCP-032’s creators
had some kind of animosity towards a particular
member of personnel and that 032 was part
of some kind of revenge plot against a member
of Foundation staff.
SCP-032 denied this though, stating “He
is not one of you.
Merely a one-time sympathizer, of sorts.
He believes you tried to help him once, and
if he is forced here, if he finds me here,
you will die.
That will hurt him.
They have no interest in any of you, or your
organization.
You are here as a tool, just as I am.”
According to SCP-032, the man coming to collect
her was a prideful, complacent figure, who
“won when he should have lost”.
Somehow, this individual had apparently been
punished by being forced to live in exile
from his kin and wander the world endlessly,
destroying anything in his path, yet unwillingly.
His very presence would poison human beings,
leaving this man trapped in eternal solitude,
tormented by the weight of his guilty conscience.
SCP-032 described the man’s punishment as
a “masterwork of torment”.
She described her purpose in being sent to
the Foundation as being to act as this man’s
last undoing.
Apparently, this wanderer would occasionally
find solace in looking at nature, and find
hope in the world around him.
Her ability to destroy the organisms around
her would be a way to break this man’s will,
the final nail in the proverbial coffin.
Apparently, SCP-032’s appearance was also
seemingly meant to deceive him.
She stated that the man would recognize her
and this would remind him of fond memories,
but then as he got closer he would see SCP-032
for what she really was, a crude replica of
a human being, reminding this man that her
likeness would be forever out of his reach.
SCP-032 was intended, by her creators, to
be as artificial as the wandering man’s
hope, and when he eventually found her, either
in a day, a month, or in a century, she would
destroy his very last source of solace.
At the conclusion of the interview, Doctor
Kovac asked why this man would recognize her,
and SCP-032 simply replied “I used to be
his wife.”
If we take SCP-032 at her word, then it appears
she was created with the intention of being
used to torment this wandering man and act
as a final punishment for him.
In another interview six months after her
initial containment, SCP-032 expressed a hatred
for the man’s wife whom she was made to
resemble.
Sent in to assess SCP-032’s cognitive abilities,
and personality - or lack of - Doctor Kovac
questioned this.
SCP-032 had always been adamant that she had
no conscious thoughts or feelings of her own,
and when challenged by the doctor, she claimed
that she hated her “mold” because her
creators wanted her to.
The first thing SCP-032’s creators had done
after making her was show her the wife of
the man they hoped to torment.
It is unclear whether SCP-032 was shown photographs
or the actual woman she had been molded from.
Not an easy task as this woman, the wife,
was apparently long dead.
But the creators had risked disturbing the
wife’s final rest, just to show her to SCP-032.
“She was beautiful.
So peaceful, serene.
Whole.
Even gone, even dead, I could see the essence
of who she used to be… of who she still
was, and forever will be.
Her soul.
They told me she didn't get to live for all
that long, but when she lived… she was herself.
She was alive.
And so I hated her.”
In the wife’s face, SCP-032 saw a reflection
of herself, and realized that she had been
made just to be a mockery, a parody of a living
human being, existing only to cause misery
to the wandering man who would one day find
her.
Instead of skin, she had molded silicone and
plastic, synthetic fiber in place of hair
and oil for blood.
But what SCP-032 lacked, she realized, was
a soul.
This was all part of the Brothers’ design,
according to SCP-032.
When the man found her, he would see not only
what had been done to the memory of his wife.
But he’d also see how much SCP-032 hated
her, and hated herself for not being alive
the same way the wife had been.
The goal of all this?
To make the man realize that he never won.
SCP-032 herself is a mystery, but perhaps
the real question is: Who do you think this
man is, and what was it he didn’t win?
But that’s a story for another day.
Let us know what you think down in the comments…
Now go check out “SCP-5545 - Mysterious
Tunnels in Antarctica - ABNORMALITY” and
“SCP-1730 - What Happened to Site-13?
The Full Story Compilation” for more of
the most mysterious SCPs!